.
Let's assume that I have point 3, -4
Ie will be 1, 2, 3 and 4 down
1, 2, 3, 4
These are 3, -4
I also have point 6.1
If 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 1
So
6.1
In the last offer, we found that we can use
Pythagoras theory if we want to find
The distance between these two points
We draw a triangle here and realize that this
Tendon
In this presentation, I will try to find what is
The focal point is located halfway between
This cat and that point?
If this distance, any line that
Up between them
Now what is the axial point exactly lies
Half way between the two?
What is the coordinates?
It is a number, number
And to do that - let me draw it even more here
Because I think you will find it
Very direct
At first it looks like a difficult issue
Let me use the space formula with some variables
But you'll see, it's one of the simplest
The things you will learn in algebra and geometry
Let's assume that this is a triangle
That is the triangle
This is point 6.1
The ones at the bottom are point 3, -4
We are looking for a point to fall
Between these two points
What are its coordinates?
Sounds tough at first, but it's easy when you think
In terms of x and y coordinates
How long will the x coordinate?
This line shows that x = 6
This is here - let me do it in a dark color--
This illustrates that x = 6
This shows that x = 3
How much will this x coordinate?
Well, the x-coordinate will occur
Between x coordinates
This is x = 3, and this is x = 6
It will be between them
This distance will be equal to this distance
The x coordinate will be located in the middle between
3 and 6
What we call the number that lies between
The 3 and 6?
It can be called a midpoint, or we can call it
Average, or average, or whatever we like
To call it
We just want to know what is the rate of 3 and 6?
And until we find this point, the point is halfway between 3
And 6, we find this, 3 + 6/2
Equal to 4.5
If this is an x ​​coordinate, it is 4.5
Let me draw this graphically
1, 2, 3, 4.5
As you can see, it lies between them
This is an x ​​coordinate
Now, with the same logic, the Y coordinate
Will be in the middle between y = -4 and y
= 1
It will be between them
This is x
And y will be between y =
-4 and y = 1
If we take the rate
1 + -4 / 2
This equals 3 / 2- or can say
1.5
1.5 at the bottom
Located right here
So
We take the x rate, and take the rate
The y, or maybe you should say that the average is
More specific
Average of two points
You will get the midpoint of these two points
The point is quite midway between them
It's the midpoint of the line that connects them
If the coordinates are 4.5, -1.5
Let us solve more of these examples
These, in fact, you'll find
Very direct
But to review it, let me represent it graphically
Let's assume I have point 4, -5
If 1, 2, 3, 4
Then down to 5
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
If those are 4, -5
I have point 8.2
If 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 2
8.2
So what is the coordinates of the midpoint
These two points?
The point that lies between them?
Well, take the x rate, and take the y rate
If the midpoint is going to be - x values ​​are 8 and 4
Will be 8 + 4/2
And the y value will be - well, we have 2 and
We get 2 + -5 / 2
how much?
12/2 = 6, 2 - 5 = -3
3/2 = -1.5
If this is the midpoint
Just take the x and y, or
We find the average
Let's do it, so make sure
From it it looks like a midpoint
6, -5
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
1.5
-1, -1.5
Yes, looks good
It seems to be located halfway between this point and
That point
Now that's all you need to remember
X, or x, or x
Which lies between these two
And y rate
Get to the midpoint
What I will explain to you now is in the textbook
If I have point x1 y1, then
The point - in fact, I will write it in yellow
It's always tired to change color - then
I have point x2 y2, many books will give you something
The formula is called the midpoint
Again, I think it's naive to keep it
But just remember, we take the rate
We find the x that lies between them, and we find the y that lies between them
If the formula is midpoint
Midpoint Formula
What is already said here is the midpoint - so perhaps we will say
Midpoint x - Or maybe I'll call it that way
I better labels
Dot x and midpoint = y
- This will give you the format x1 + x2 / 2
Then y1 + y2 / 2
It seems that you have to keep it
But all you have to say, see
This is a rate, or average
These two numbers
I gather them
I gather them together and swear on 2, we gather these two
With each other, we divide on 2
So get a fair point
That's all about the midpoint
.